à
oyez
ma mère m'a dit antoine vetro péniche le
quai ligny ma mère dans pas tant que je
ne les garde pas
et basta
aurier
quand tu bosses écoutent la radio me
réveillant c'était yvette horner qui
jouait de la corvée au temps accordé en
boutique bijoux et le temps plein
auriez
vous les
connaissez pas
il a bien la cagnotte
on y est
e
avec mon petit cousin kiabi sans point
guard égreneuses sa télévision
anoci l'année pas de piment boehner qui
n'est pas financé je sais qu'on m'attend
mourier
le juge a dit agile vous avez
j'ai fait ma part n'importe danger les
mecs le jeune homme
mais bah quand je la connais moins que
je rate
aurier
est
réellement plus amusant on verrait
détaillants dans les couloirs et sonia
hallyday
oyez
aurier
si je porte une chemise à fleurs c'est
que je suis en avant deux ou trois
longueurs ce n'est qu'une question de
ses sens et votre nantes-le encore
inquiéter tout le temps
pariez
j'ai retiré les troubles la présidence
demandant antoine dulin têtu
comment faire pour arrêt sur le pays
c'était l'habitude la banque dans les
monoprix